Steve Bannon has been talking up Bobby
Kennedy Jr and his conspiracy theories
for a while Steve Bannon isn't stupid
and Steve Bannon sees Bobby Kennedy Jr
as an agent of chaos he can generate
chaos he can generate chaos by
potentially being a stumbling block for
Joe Biden on the path to his
renomination he could be a stumbling
block for media that might not be
interested in a contested Democratic
primary or whatever the case may be this
is a huge part of why these folks are
now saying Bobby Kennedy Jr it's
absolutely great stuff
so the more we understand about what's
going on the more concerned it should
make us but not just because these
people like Bobby Kennedy Jr but because
of the positions he holds on many issues
as I've outlined to you over the last
several weeks